you play Hawkeye in the Avengers yeah
and we is it true you were kind of
pissed at first like you got into this
Avengers movie which i think is cool and
being a superhero I think it's great I
was a big comic book reader when I was a
kid I loved all these comic book movies
I loved seeing it come to life
but it was like as a great actor as you
are you were probably like hey man
they're not giving me any lines here
you've got a little bit of aggravated
with this character right well I mean I
always will always just wanted more you
know it's it's maybe I'm insatiable or
maybe I just want to get out of second
gear if you will it's like well it's
kind of yeah you know it's like it's you
know it's use all the gears here there's
something it's like this remake it is
interesting as possible and you know
there's a lot of moving parts and a lot
of moving pieces in that giant amazing
world it hasn't created but it's it's
growing more and more and you've done
two of those movies right I can't
remember it did two Avengers to it one
is a there's a captain man there's a lot
of them it'll be a lock I moved I don't
know that's outside my paygrade when
they came to you did they just come to
you and say look we want you to play
Hawkeye you don't have to audition
anymore I mean for that kind of crap
yeah yeah I think was kind of like that
yeah yeah I do you we do like you
probably like the first one you don't
even get to be with Robert Downey jr.
like they put me in a [ __ ] scene with
Robert Downey jr. yeah that was really
the main reason why I wanted to do it
cuz I really like what they did with the
Iron Man and then they offered this
Hawkeye role which is a guy that um had
a
I don't knows no he's just a skillset
guy he's nothing like a nice superpower
Mike okay I get I can do that
you getting in on that comic-con action
I've been to a few is it annoying - you
know it's actually one of the few few
times you can kind of interact with fans
you know it says it's actually really
nice that's that's nice yeah yeah in a
different way you're not sitting at a
table signing autographs you're in the
room in the question-and-answer those
are the best parts of the comic-con yeah
yes when you're you guys just have a one
on not one on one beer yeah you do these
sort of conferences and get to the fans
and they have questions and you don't
get to sit at a table and charge for
autograph and there's the little kid
like the joy on a little child's faces
you know it's really one of the most
magnetic beautiful sort of gifts that
I've ever been given knowing that you
know I'm affecting them in some sort of
way you know